ah custodies or sell surplus apples five
cents piece on the street corner and if
you're bewildered panicky at what's
happening to you in your country you
aren't alone because biggest industrialist has
openly admitted I am afraid every man is raid
prosperity is just around the corner say the
hopeful headlines but around the corners wind the
lengthening breadlines and a whole new class of
citizens appears in American society the new poor
and whether charity can no longer carry the
burden the states are forced to act the New
York Governor Franklin Roosevelt is the first to
supply direct emergency relief to the unemployed
the same paralysis that lames the city's
blights the farms and out in the country
two men are asking what's wrong what's happening
farm prices have dropped disastrously and a man's
work no longer brings him a just return the
threat of foreclosure of losing house and home
spreads through the conservative farmlands
and radical talk is boiling into action
in Iowa the farmers the crisis spread political
economic social centered on the white house in
the face of a hostile press and a divided
Congress Herbert Hoover makes unprecedented
use of government power to encourage recovery
but his fundamental faith is in the rugged
individualism of the American people and in
private enterprise economic depression he says
cannot be cured by legislative action but the
basic causes of the deepening crisis remains
stubbornly obscure even to the business leaders
summoned to the White House the explanation
offered by humorist Robert Benchley is as good
as any now what were the primary causes of the
depression as we called it over productions now
adjustments in gold distributions overproduction
inflation too little thyroid secretions or
flats disease too much verbal overproduction
and by the same token under production then
too there was the Gulf Stream all of these
help will lead to inflation deflation and
overproduction with a consequence depression
many are beyond joking a report
from Detroit says men are sitting
in the forks all day long out
of work muttering to themselves
some succumbed to apathy some are swept by alarm
and bank after bank across the country is hit by
panic withdrawals new lines appear on American
streets depositors swarming to snatch out what
savings they have left before it's too late banks
by the hundreds by the thousands are forced to
close on the eve of the presidential election of
1932 the whole financials the quakes and Tatars
a bitter electorate of frightened people
turns overwhelmingly against the party and
power turns hopefully toward a new national
leader Franklin D Roosevelt a new day in New
Times and who can say what will happen before
another morning rolls around things are going
on all the time nowadays that would have
seemed impossible a few years ago some
people worried what effect all these changes
and reforms will have in the long run but the
new dealers say people don't eat in the long
run they eat every day so the changes keep
coming what's going to happen next we
don't know we can't say we're wondering